all right so there was the shooting at
the Mohammed cartoon contest near Dallas
Texas so a couple things here I want to
be very clear on something you cannot
shoot someone in America for using their
freedom of expression and their free
speech even if they say something you
don't like you have the right to free
speech not the right to not be offended
now you can make plenty of arguments
that Pamela Geller the woman who set
this thing up is a bigot and a hate
monger and doesn't like Muslim people
and guess what in America you're allowed
to not like people and allowed to say
terrible things and if there was a
conference where they didn't like Jewish
people and they were putting up
anti-jewish cartoons guess what you
don't get to shoot that up either that's
what's going on here this is about
freedom of speech it's about nothing
else and it's a slippery slope so you
can't say this is or intentionally
inflaming people just to upset them and
somehow that makes it more wrong no you
don't get to shoot people just because
you don't like what they said it's
really as simple as that